I do you want to get to the met credits
scene sure because we do find that it
ties into the much larger universe and
everything that's happened and I mean
yeah yeah yeah was that kind of a
mandate passed down from Marvel saying
hey you do got to tie it into to
infinity war or was that something that
you had always wanted to do well we knew
from the very beginning in this movie we
knew we were gonna follow infinity war
and we knew how infinity war ended what
we did not know was how we were gonna
integrate that or if we were going to
into our movie and throughout the script
writing process you know we tried
various things where we seated in you
know during the course of our story like
oh there's a monitor in the background
and it seems like something's going on
somewhere else in the world and but we
felt like we'd seen that conceit before
and it didn't seem that interesting to
us so we finally landed on the structure
which is you know the finished movie
that you saw and we really liked the
idea because the question always was in
our head how does the Ant Man and the
wasp universe deal with this giant event
at the end of infinity war because if
you if you do it early in the movie it's
gonna just take over the movie that's
all you're gonna think about right um so
we then really liked the idea that we
end our movie and we sort of tie up
everybody's stories in this very neat Bo
Scott's off house arrest he's back with
Cassie ex-con the guys have landed the
big client and the the company's not
gonna go under and Scott and hope are
together and they seem like they're
gonna work as a partnership and Hank his
rescue Janet and maybe they're gonna
have a little vacation everything's
great q The Partridge Family Q a
colorful Mane on ends title sequence and
then BAM hit the audience with this this
scene and and and the scene itself was
obviously something that there was a lot
of discussion about I think Marx and
McFeely you know who have written
Captain America movies and the Avengers
movies they I think took the first pass
at it because we were trying to figure
out sort of what the elements could be
and one of the things we wanted to do in
that scene was throw a lot of the
audience all at once you come in where
are they they're on the roof of a
parking deck oh there's Janet Van Dyne
and she's kind of in street
close that's new and different and then
wait there's Louis's van and Scott's in
the suit and hopes handing him his thing
and wait there he's going in the quantum
round like so many things that would
sort of get the audience wondering what
the mission is in a man and what are
they doing right so that hopefully
they're a little off balance even though
they're expecting something some
acknowledgement of infinity war from the
very beginning of our movie we decided
very deliberately people were gonna go
in and I think after we all saw the
finished version of infinity war after
we were done shooting it became even
more evident that audiences Marvel fans
are gonna come into this movie looking
for clues and we don't give them any for
a long time yeah and then when they sort
of just give up and submit to the movie
and watch the movie and then at the end
we catch them that's that's exactly what
happens though because you guys
acknowledge civil war so then I'm like
okay well we're back here we're not even
we're not even getting that exactly and
then you get to the end in the once he
goes in and I'm like wait a second my
lowly a slowly building sense of dread
was what we were after and once there's
that sort of you know the countdown is
interrupted and then it was a matter of
who yeah giveth and taketh away
yeah Janet yeah we had we had versions
you know we talked about a lot about
who's gonna be up there with them and at
one point you know it's like do we have
is Bill Foster there is is Ava there and
one of the things that guided us wishes
is just the math of infinity war you
know fifty percent right is the thing so
it's sort of we felt like what we did
was the correct way to do it just Scott
being in the quantum realm did that
protect him from that oh I don't know we
might we'll just have to wait and see
what happens I don't know man
you
[Music]